for some analysis now we have with us in
the studio Rick Nowak correspondent for
the Washington Post good morning to you
Rick
does Cohen's guilty plea mean that the
president broke the law
well it certainly makes it more likely
that people that investigators will
figure out that he did break the law in
case what Cohen said was in fact true
but whether that's gonna have any legal
consequences that's a totally different
question
okay the legal consequence right now is
the possibility of indictment for the
u.s. president how likely is that
scenario well that's an area is not very
likely at the moment because the
Department of Justice has actually done
a few analyses in the past and they have
always concluded that indicted were
charging a sitting president is simply
impossible so you would have to have a
prosecutor who is willing to take the
risk to challenge that okay um you know
we've seen legal troubles for the
president before and for his associates
I'm thinking of General Michael Flynn
one example is the Cohen case different
than that
well the Cohen case is different because
it directly implicates the President
himself and that is to a large extent
different because it could have legal
ramifications a legal impact beyond his
term it could in fact lead to criminal
charges after the after the end of his
term after the end of his term but not
right now Democrats have in these kind
of situations especially with the
Michael Flynn situation raised the
possibility of impeachment it's way too
early to talk about that yet that is out
there in terms of what the Democrats
strategic interests are well it is too
early to speculate about impeachment but
certainly if the midterms changed the
political balance in Washington and if
the Democrats take the house that
becomes a possibility at least
triggering impeachment hearings would
become a possibility and in fact there
are certain Democrats who are already
demanding this okay Rick let's get our
viewers the background on that second
case that that could put a pressure on
the US president
and that's another former Trump
associate his former campaign manager
Paul Manafort has been found guilty by a
jury on eight charges the judge declared
a mistrial on ten other counts now
Manafort was convicted of filing false
tax returns in connection with millions
of dollars earned lobbying for Ukraine
failing to disclose offshore bank
accounts and two counts of bank fraud
man affords crimes came to light as part
of the investigation into possible
Russian influence on the 2016 election
campaign while President Trump commented
on that verdict after learned landing in
Charleston West Virginia where he
attended a rally a lot of different
people over the years and I feel very
sad about that
it doesn't involve me but I still feel
with you know it's a very sad thing that
happens this has nothing to do with
Russian collusion this started as
Russian collusion this has apps
nothing to do this is a witch hunt and
it's a disgrace okay we continue the
witch hunt term that the presidents use
quite often Rick wise the president
defended mana fort but made absolutely
very lengthy defense there but made no
comment about going well we know that
he's been struck yesterday more by the
news of Cohen Cohen pleading guilty done
by the mana Ford verdict but um also
there might be some legal obstacles here
because those are two very different
cases you have a former lung or at one
time campaign manager and then you have
his lawyer and there are different legal
implications for defending those person
this person okay um what are prison
Trump's political options right now you
mentioned the midterm elections they're
coming up in November are they that much
more of a higher stakes game for the
political survival of the president well
they could become that if the Democrats
decide to make that their rallying cry
on there are two options I think um
either
this could embolden Trump's supporters
who consider all of those investigations
deeply unfair or it could important on
the Democrats who managed to finally
rally their supporters behind himself so
it's sort of unclear what what kind of
impact it would be okay so it could fuel
both bases both the Trump base and the
Democrats as well how are both these
cases likely to effect and that's still
out there the Moller investigation what
we just saw the president call a witch
hunt into possible Russian collusion on
the baha behalf of the Trump campaign
well the question here is whether those
prosecutions and in fact the possibility
of going to jail for more than four
years in both cases would in fact result
in both of them cooperating with Merlin
and sharing additional information about
Trump deadly play into that very
separate investigation and I think that
is what what a lot of people involved in
the Merlin probe
are hoping okay that there might be some
statements and in terms of sentencing
presenting sentencing statements that
could implicate the president well I'm
talking mainly about a possibility of
cooperation between men affords and
Cohen and the Miller investigation and
that is still something that is a hope
okay for the Moller investigation but
Novak from The Washington Post thanks so
much for being with us today thanks so
much